oh it's all then let's do something okay
you want to go
do something [ __ ]
there we go let's do something
[Music]
Mr Lewis
thank you for coming in
with your Associates
I know this is hard to hear but we need
to make some serious decisions about
your mother's health
let's be honest she is getting on in
years oh
snap okay I see how it is I see how it
is well yo mama so old her last name is
osaurus
no Mr Lewis it wasn't an insult I I was
just saying that your mother's condition
is deteriorating because she's getting
older oh see that's cold though that's a
cold one okay okay I see how it is hey
yo yo mama so old in her history class
they just wrote down what they was doing
this isn't an insult contest not only is
your mother elderly but also her ability
to walk is currently being affected by
her weight oh see okay it just got real
no I'm not insulting her I'm trying to
tell you your mama is so fat
we should go to the movie theater [ __ ]
that's the everyone
[Music]
listen to me okay your mother needs to
manage her weight or there can be some
real problems
oh okay
yo mama is so fat she need a latitude
and longitude number to fight her old
[ __ ]
[Applause]
now who's the doctor I Am the Doctor Mr
Lewis I am and it is my job to make sure
that your mother is getting the care
that she needs we are talking about the
woman who took care of you your whole
life the least you can do is take care
of her in her old age and take this
seriously
I'm sorry I'm sorry that I lost my
temper
no really doctor
I guess I was just joking around because
I know her condition is really serious
and
I don't know I guess humor is the only
way I could really deal with it oh
I just know that she said so many times
she doesn't want anything invasive died
brilliant
I was not aware of that that's
interesting because she did not mention
that to me in our previous conversation
because
it was difficult to hear her with my
dick in her mouth
snap Mr Lewis
oh snap
now let's talk about the procedure
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this Saturday night this is not even
gonna be a fight I'm on mercy kill this
old man
I will torture his body
so that his soul learns to be humble I'm
gonna dance around him while he tried to
hit me with his Cane oh man
God trust me for this fight
God is the teacher Derek is the student
and I am God's instrument
when I squeeze your lungs Derek and you
beg me for life
then your heart will open up to the Lord
I'm going to knock him out round one
[ __ ]
wait
what do you saying
that God chose him
don't even make sense really
when you eat through plastic too
because you are paralyzed from neck down
burn your family
will gather around your hospital bed
it's a new day
okay he know we just talking here right
I mean we just we just getting people
interested in the fight because I'm I'm
sorry is this crazy
godsless
are so beautiful
guys lessons are beautiful I'm sorry who
put this fight together this is a well
how I do if y'all got an actual crazy
person to meet for me to fight well
that's not fair to me or him
no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
[Music]
what you mean you can't find it
but where is he
yo man where my manager at Steve how's
it
[Music]
listen to fight everybody's been waiting
for but when I get Andre in the rain man
it's gonna be cruel and quick because
it's gonna be like one two one two boom
and you out man [ __ ] you Claudius Lewis
I'm gonna [ __ ] you right in the ass yeah
I'm gonna bend you over and right in the
air all right you know what Andre he
like to be trying to get into his
opponent's hairs by saying crazy stuff
he ain't gonna get into my head he ain't
gonna get into my head no I'm not gonna
get in your head I'm going to get in
your ass just like I said this right up
in there and that tiny little minuscule
of yours this is what's going to happen
I'm gonna take you to a nice high fancy
highfalutin restaurant I'm gonna buy you
things whine and dine you and we're
gonna find some things that we have in
common and they're going to become
inside jokes to us and then we're just
going to laugh about them in the taxi
all the way to your house where I'm
gonna [ __ ] you in the ass
oh okay now
does me personally
I've never you know I never seen Andre
take it that far before
but
whatever yeah whatever I'll tell you
whatever whatever I'm finally gonna feel
comfortable taking you out to dinner
parties and then all of our friends were
also couples they're just gonna laugh at
us because we're that couple that holds
hands all the time let me tell you
something Claudius we love each other so
very much that no matter how tired I am
no matter how much [ __ ] I've dealt
with over the day I'm just gonna leave
it at the door when I hit you in the ass
okay you know what man it's time for you
to stop all that nonsense right now all
right
he just said he was going to take me to
dinner parties he did say dinner parties
gonna snuggle on the couch every night
I'm gonna let you pick the movie even
though you always pick the movie then
I'm going to take you out for a walk on
the beach and the Moonlight is going to
bounce off of your scalp and I'm just
gonna kiss you so tenderly while the
waves break and then right there right
then I'm gonna win the Sandy ass all
right it's time for you to search up for
your mouth yes it is time it's time for
you to shut your mouth we're gonna spend
the golden years together yeah yeah I'm
gonna support you all the way through
your run through city council yeah
that's right you're going to be tired
and exhausted but we're still gonna find
the energy to go antiquing on the
weekend then you're gonna be on your
deathbed and you're gonna be sitting
there and you're gonna be dying I'm
gonna be right beside you and I'm gonna
be crying and right at that moment when
you cross over from this world into the
next
[Music]
no I love the village as much as the
next guy but I'm telling you if we
continue to self-segregate ourselves the
entire gay community is going to
continue to be modernized I was just
saying this to Claudius the other night
right after I found him in the ass yeah
he did he did
anyway enough politics cheers everyone
cheers
all right
all right how's everybody how's
everybody doing
all right and you guys can all hear me
okay yeah all right I know this guy can
right here boy this guy's ears are so
big he's laughing at jokes from the yuck
yuck Club all the way on the other side
of town
all right
and you sir you're doing okay right and
you're getting enough to eat is that
even possible
thank you sir folks I'm sorry I'm gonna
get everybody tonight I'm gonna nobody
is safe I'm getting everybody except for
you sir I'm Gonna Leave You Alone just
like your date did tonight hello
[Applause]
hey ma'am I get it you have breasts okay
geez man look at this chick over here
her cleavage is giving the Grand Canyon
an inferiority complex
[Laughter]
who's who's talking right now
[Music]
yeah hey man look at that look at that
pink shirt you got on there wow where'd
you get that queertshirts.com
I am gay though
okay go for it I can take it hmm
oh yeah yeah no hey yeah don't you worry
about that man
gloves are coming off
right there right there what's with the
three drinks man we alcoholic much
this is my pain medication of course it
is it's your pain medication because uh
he is in pain
right now
make fun of the what did you say because
here's the problem sir is it's really
dark in here and sorry are you burned
because I can't make it out thanks so
much ma'am for Illuminating him thank
you that's uh I appreciate that
oh
those Burns
sir I don't know
okay well no you know what I feel like a
wheelchair look sir there is nothing
funny about you being in a wheelchair
and we can all but there is something
funny about me being fat
all right all right fine fine I've got
it I've got it I'm doing it I'm doing it
I just didn't want to go after this guy
because I didn't want him to kill me in
my dreams
like like Freddy Krueger
[Music]
because no
Disney now Freddy Krueger's face is
burned off
that's not
[Music]
you asked
he said he could take it that's what he
said
but I can't how is this on me how do we
even know if he's crying right now
[Applause]
well I don't know that sound it just
sounds like an electronic sound
he said he could take it
okay
and I'm trying to help people no okay
you know what Jacqueline I don't know
what you need to think about yourself
sometimes before you start insinuating
yourself in other people's business well
you know what be nice I'm gonna
insinuate myself whenever and wherever I
please because it's a free country [ __ ]
and that's all you're doing call me a
[ __ ] again
I would
love to see what happens oh you do oh
absolutely so why don't you come and
bring it then [ __ ]
see no you are riding my last nerve and
I ain't even playing no more I am not
even playing no more oh it's all then
let's do something okay you want to go
do something [ __ ] huh there we go let's
do something
let's do something [ __ ] what
we told you not to mess with us [ __ ]
y'all just saw that [ __ ] turning into
two little girls right
[Music]